- [Instructor] So, we are asked,
question mark is roughly equal
to this squiggly equal
sign right over here,
this means roughly equal to,
so not exactly equal to
44 times 78.
So one way to think about
it is, 44 times 78 is
roughly equal to what?
So they're really asking us to estimate.
So I encourage you to pause this video
and try to think through
how you would estimate
what 44 times 78 is.
Once again, you don't
have to get it exactly,
you just want to get it roughly.
And think about which of these choices
are closest to that estimation of yours.
All right now, let's
work through it together.
So for me, the best way to
estimate is to think about,
"Hey, can I think of these numbers,
"can I estimate these numbers,
"or think about what are
they roughly equal to?"
And when I think about what
they're roughly equal to I want
to think about numbers that are easy
to multiply potentially in my head.
So for example 44 is
reasonably close to 40,
so I could say that,
"Hey this is approximately
equal to or roughly equal to 40,
"so that's my estimate of
44, or 44 is roughly 40."
And then 78 I could say,
"Hey, that's pretty close
to 80" and so I could say,
"This is roughly equal to 40 times 80,"
and this is pretty straight forward.
Some of you might already recognize
that four times eight is 32,
and then we have four tens
and then we have eight tens,
so it would be four times
eight times 10 twice.
But if what I just said
is confusing to you,
we could think about it this way.
40 times 80 is the same
thing as four times 10,
that's 40, times eight
times 10, that's 80,
and this is equal to, I'm just
gonna switch the order here
of this multiplication which we can do,
this is equal to four times
eight times 10 times 10,
four times eight is 32,
10 times 10 is 100.
So we can say that this
is equal to 32 hundreds,
or we could view that as 3,200,
which we could also view as 32 hundreds.
And so that is this
choice right over here.
Now this isn't exactly
what 44 times 78 is,
but it's roughly, and this is useful.
Sometimes in life, you just
have to get a rough sense
of what something is going to be.
Sometimes when you even are
trying to find this exact
product, your brain wants to
check does that make sense?
Let say you went through some
process to figure out this,
and you got some number
that is close to 20, and you're
like, "Wait, wait a minute"
But roughly when I
think about 40 times 80,
this should be close to 3,200,
I must have done something wrong.
So it also helps you
keep a check on yourself.